تحديد
[موسيقى]
تصوير
سوف تعطي
حكواتي
[موسيقى]
لدي
مشاكل المياه الخاصة بك.
هي
ماشا مؤخرا
[موسيقى]
يمكن لبعضها البعض ثم قدم وبالتالي
بعد ذلك قال أن مثل هذا التجفيف
غوجي هو الأفضل
من قانون العنف الأسري
انها البيرة كانت يد
أنا لم أقطع بسكين
هدم بلا دم شكرا لك عندما
فرك اليدين قال لا
قاد سيارة ولم يضرب الأطفال بأحد
الكاميرا ولعب الجميع الرجل ما نحن عليه
لنكن ربما اندفاعة المنزل مثل
ذهب إلى جانب السمكة اتجه ن إلى الحقل
تاتيانا أوشيروكو ضرورية لمبدأ كليموف
قلص طارق أو أولغا قبل الميلاد خارج النافذة
مثل هذا الآس للراحة على الثلج.
عندما أتعب قال الإصدار
لا تستطيع المستودعات النزول على ما هو عليه
هذه ليست كلمات فارغة ، يحدث ذلك غالبًا
كان هنا هنا
أوقف السيارة وأخبرني أن أخرج
لذلك هذا هو المكان الذي أنت فيه
سوف ندفن
كما لو كان هنا
توقف بالفعل ثم ضرب
أنا بالفعل لضربة أخرى في الرأس
لقد سقطت كان مثل الثلج
عندما كنت أكذب بالفعل اتضح على اليسار
الجانب
لقد فشل في الجزء الأيمن
ضربات وبعد ذلك أخذ سكين
قدمه بيده اليسرى التي ضغط عليها بالفعل
و
التمرير اتضح هنا أدناه
المفتاح هنا سهل وبعد ذلك يكون إلى حد ما
بمجرد التقديم هنا اختر البيوتين
عارية تحقق مباشرة أم لا بعد
قال أن مثل هذه العاهرة المؤخرات
أفضل ما تم مسحه لي هو أنه لا أحد
أرجل
قال وداعا الآن هذا عندما بالفعل
زحف إلى الطريق
أضاءت على جانب الطريق ، كيف حالك
اليدين ثم إلى المدخل ذاته
وذهب إلى ما إذا كان الرجل الإسكندر أحسنا
على الإطلاق أنه توقف عن الضغط علي
بالفعل لدينا سمك الثدي الكتان عض هنا لي
دخلت بالفعل في غيبوبة لمدة ثلاثة أيام إلى 4 أيام
خرج من غيبوبة والحقيقة طبيعية نعم هي كذلك
بعنف أنها قاسية كما لو كنت تبدأ
تذكر مع أي عيون عليك
بدا وكأنه كان كل شيء قدر الإمكان
بهدوء فقط مثل هذا لأخذ سكين
نكزة وتحويل الرجل انه على قيد الحياة
لحم جسد حي وأنا هنا عدة مرات
أنا أحضر لي هنا هذا المستوى
سجل سكين مكدسة الملتوية عليه
التمرير
عرفات تاتيانا أو مكسيم كليموف روبل
لسلطة التبولة الصيفية
و nagumo حسنًا ، أنا نفسي لست هذه الشارا ، أنا نفسي
تخدم ساعات xan من خلال إعطاء الأسماك اللعنة
فاز هيدرا على كل ما في كثير من الأحيان
المغتصبون المنزليون ، دعنا نقول فقط إنهم لا يفعلون ذلك
مختلف عن الناس العاديين
كن هناك لطيف لطيف
الشخص في الاتصال من يستطيع
تعال إلى المنزل هناك أنا أفعل ذلك هناك
فقط هذه الأشياء الفظيعة ونحن نراها
في العديد من الحالات لتبدأ بالأمثلة
بالمناسبة ، ضغطت لي ليرا واتصلت به
لكن
[موسيقى]
العضلة متصلة بالمستشعر هنا على السطح الخارجي
من الداخل أتخيل ذلك
إغلاق أو فتح يد
تشنج العضلات ويعمل المستشعر
أمسك بالملعقة بيدي اليسرى وأتناول الطعام
إذا تركت جيدًا ، من الناحية النظرية ، يمكن تناول أطقم الأسنان
كما أنني لا أستطيع أن أفعل ذلك تافهًا
المهارات الحركية الدقيقة لا أستطيع ربط الأزرار
صغير لا استطيع تجميع شعري جيدا ماذا
ثم الأشياء لا تزال هناك قص أظافرك يا أطفال
لا أستطيع أن أفعل هذا لذا أنا نوعا ما
اليد اليمنى أو اليسرى على الفور
[تصفيق]
هذا واحد للنظام الغذائي مارغريتا جراشيفا
dawson السقوط مع النخيل على خدمة tryphy
تاتوما زويا وانا ماريفات هي مزهرية و
حتى قناة نعم وعزر ليانغ
هناك حليب لوتريك وله سمكة الجحيم
قطعت بالفعل وصدره sayar حركته
بالنسبة إلى المحاسبة عبر googled ، يعطي كل من win min يعطي 5
نعم أنا
docs قناة kybaman فرض أ
أداء يعتقد أنه كان جيدًا هناك
أكثر من 10 أيام أعتقد أنه فهم ذلك
سيقطع يديه جيدًا على وجه التحديد ، مثلي
أعتقد أنه لا يوجد عمل
هناك حق لقطع اليدين وإلحاق الضرر
عنف لرجل مهما فعل
اقلب الناس قضية مارغريتا جراشيفا
وعلى سبيل المثال ديمتري غراتشيف كل شيء
تميز بشكل إيجابي فقط
مؤنس كصديق قادر
مساعدة ليست جدا
شخص عدواني ، وهذا هو ، من حيث المبدأ
كل هذه الطبيعة الإيجابية تحت
نعلم أنه إذا
ماذا يعني أني أرى نعم ولم تطرق
جاء هذا الوقت بعد
استمتع بوقتك وابدأ
أنا فقط استعجل لقذف لي
العناصر
لا أعتقد أنه كان لدي وقت وهي تقوم بالتدريس
zorin press i igor semenov mondes
حضانة مين تاجانروج
هذا بالفعل بحري وأنا أدخن وما إلى ذلك
الاحتفالات ، ثم نسلم ، نفصل المخرج ، الموقد
حبات الموزمبيق وسانيا
ربما بعد ذلك استنفدنا الحقائق
أطباق مناسبة وحتى تل مولار هناك
أنا أطير بعيدًا في رحلة عمل معي هناك
هناك سجل يتواصلون معه بشكل جيد
واكتشف أن لدي صلة بـ
بعض التعارف
شكرا له على العمل الرائع
في الليل جاءوا إلى منزلنا بشيء
درس هناك
محرك الصور وسيفهمه للدخول 10
الجسد والعقل هل تعاني من السرطان أم أنها سائقة
بالفعل بعد ذلك الساحر أو الناس والكلاب
canina me الاعتداء من جانبها
هناك بدأت في إلقاء الأشياء لضربي
حسناً ، لقد عانيت لفترة رثة
فجرها ثم الديون على رمح بذلك
pashutina صفعة صفعة بعض
لحظة سقوطها صفعة إنه عنف
التاريخ ولكن
من جانبها والاعتداء النفسي
كان
[موسيقى]
ايرينا وليونيد الكوليرا موريتي ساكانيا
الجليد روجر تاتيانكا
وهذه عليا حتى أتعجل
فيلم Resident Ocean Elsie Cinema وصنعه هو
ضربت لك بلدي 2 ضربت النسخة التجريبية عنها
ضرب الجدار بضع اللكمات حول
ضغطت تماما لقد بدأت بالفعل
قطع ليس هنا ولكن هنا لا أتذكر
اللحظة التي تحطمت فيها
له على حساب
عشاء بجانب ما تأكله معي
بوب في اللعبة هذا دمي أنا على الإطلاق
لقد جعلتهم يسرقون الأبواب ثم كلهم ​​هنا
الدم وهذا بشكل عام كل شيء في الدم
أمي في رأيي كل دفء روح هذا الباب
أعتقد أنها تستحق أكثر بشكل عام
لم يخرج لأكون صادقًا
إيرينا معنا ألفيس هي ليشا أيضًا
المنتصر باليورانيوم هو امرأة شريرة مسيطرة
dzharakhova
سعيد الحظ
[موسيقى]
ربما انتهى الأمر أنني أجريت عملية إجهاض
طلبت 28 دبابة تيترا من الناس المغادرة
أنا على وشك الهدوء أخيرا ابدأ الخياطة و
[موسيقى]
على الثمار هو الدخل Khachaturian شجرة عيد الميلاد النظام الغذائي
كيا بيكسار صور خروج الهجمات البوتالية
كريستينا ضد أنجلينا فاريا
فلوريدا هيونداي مايكل h4
[موسيقى]
أستانا
قمامة المأمونة 0 0 تكفي للجماهير
الجهد على منجم الدين الذي دل
[موسيقى]
تدور هذه القصة حول كيفية ثلاثة
طفل
أن العمر صغير جدًا بالنسبة إلى الثلاثة
الفتيات فقط ولكن وجدت واحدة فقط
كيف تنقذ حياتك
تدافع عن نفسك تقول الكثير من الفتيات
قتل والد مثل هذه القبة والفتاة
اخرج
هنا تبين أن الضحايا يقاومون
مجرم
منذ الرابع بدأت في قيادة zation
عليها إذلال مغتصبة بهذا
توقفت لحظة أن يكون والدهم نقدر ذلك
وصول إلى
إذا كان الرون يقلى حقًا ، فهذه حركة كاملة
هذه أوليا آموس بوكا ليست مجرد نتيجة
تعتقد اللجنة أنه كان
القتل بالتراضي و
أحببت كيف أغلق والديهم
الهواء عندما جاء إلى الثلاثة
واحد فقط الأختام فقدان الكحول
المال إذا تم تجميعها جميعًا في حزمة
هناك دافع للقتل ، وأنا أفهم لماذا هم
في المنزل يحترق كثيرًا ويحاولون
حماية لأنه في 4 المهندس بشكل واضح
ينفي على الشخصيات مع الانسحاب
دقائق الرحلة أو لا تكذب ، دعنا نقول
حتى ظروف العنف ضد
يتم تحديد الفتيات بوضوح من خلال التحقيق في كل شيء
هذا السؤال مغلق بالفعل
ايركوتسك
بينما أنا ضعيف خان إيمو تمتصني دينا
بالنسبة للصينيين ، أنا تاتيانا أو ماركيز
الدقيق نفسه ليس له الأنشوجة الأخرى
ناكيدا تران التايلاندية تجعل قاتلة قاتلة
هذا يمكنني أكثر من الذي كانت هذه النغمة كافية له
خلف عجلة القيادة في الشركة ، فإنك تعطي حكمة كليموف للناس
سوف يتخلى فاولر 1 عن القوس والنشاب بعد الفحص
من ركن جالينا من نوع مختلف للقراءة
قطر للتسويق
فرع المحكمة الإقليمية في إيركوتسك في
بايكال ، أنا عمومًا أمتلك عصا
لم أستطع الخروج
أثناء الركوب هنا على رأس الحافلة الثابت
ركبتيه تؤلمان بشدة انه لا يوجد مكان
عملت كسائق تاكسي في مكان ما داخل 20
هذا العمل لمدة ستة أشهر ، ربما
شهرين إلى ثلاثة أشهر ثم طُرد
ولذا فهو يشربها ليشاجرك من أجلها
قتال المتحدة لدفتر الأستاذ شرح أنك أ
اتحاد الأسد لينا جيب سانيا
إنها عواصف yarifuni أوه إنه جاهز إنه أم
يعلم
الأنثى بالضبط حوالي خمس عشرة ضربات
كان الرأس
لذلك نحن نبحث عن مشاكل في الذاكرة هنا
بدأ هذا في إطلاق النار ولم يمسكوا بي حتى أنت
ليس طبعة يد المساعدة عند الحاجة
طور
بعد هذا الحدث بكيت طويلا
قلقة منذ فترة طويلة على الجمال والوحش
حسنا مرحبا غالينا مساء الخير مرحبا
أهلا
سقطت باستمرار حاولت أن أجد
اتصل لترى
سأل الأطفال الأسئلة باستمرار عندما كنت
سأرى متى يمكنني الدردشة
الساحل حقا من حيث الفيروس وهنا و
لم يسلم جسم الطائرة
من السهل أن يكون لديك بالفعل تييرا
سيعطي أو حاد
ملزمة ل Tatra dal otseda عدت
المنزل وذلك عندما أفتح الأبواب
المصعد في الطابق العاشر ، أنا فقط
بدء الطعن
ضربت الضربة الأولى صدري في اليسار
جزء من صدرك تضربه بشكل أساسي
قلوب
بعد ذلك تمكنت من ضرب السكين
القدم كانت المنطقة كلها مغطاة بالدماء
المهاجم يخاف
كنت فقط تهرب وبقي هلام ثم و
يتم لعبها بشكل صحيح مع القهوة كلاهما يتم إعطاؤهما التقنية
أمرنا هل قابلتني
لكم أن هذا النوع لم يكن كافيا حينها
حدث ، قلت أنه أنت من
لا يزال من الضروري
في المساء جعل هذا mofo من هذا
تحويل tatiana حتى فيديو أبريل ل
أرجل من جميع الأجناس وماركيز أبسال الرياضيين
وليمة مينسك بينما ليديا الحقيقة هي
ولد الغزاة عند الامتحان
الاتحاد الروسي مع التعليم
أي نوع من الضحايا لدينا
Boyarkin مثل هذه النماذج وأين ولدت
0301 تسعون سنة حياة المدينة الجبلية
تمضي فيينا الآن إلى المحاكمة
التحقيق يرجى التصوير
توقف وفي أي يوم كل شيء
مرت المحكمة الاجتماع تركه تحت
أيها الحراس ، حسنًا ، لم يكن كل ما هو هنا
كان هناك في مكالمة جماعية
لم يحضر محاميه حتى
قصت المحكمة شعره وهو نفسه الآن
أفضل ما
من دعنا نذهب إنه حارة ماترون التي
أنا أعيش قواعد سقف جيدة جدا و
العمر كاترينا الماضي وراء ظهر رهيب
قبل أحذية berlin schulmann potion womb ثم
اليوشكا ولذا فأنا لم أزلها هنا
انا اسبح
هنا مطبخي هنا غرفة ليزا
هنا . لي
هنا تسمى امرأة ورجلي
يوجد راتب 10 في هذا وقد دفعت 3
800k قمامة خفيفة من المزرعة لدي
فقط فأر نحب النافذة لا أستطيع
لم أستطع سحب كل شيء بنفسي والعمل و
أعمالي المنزلية وأعمل أكثر مني
الطفل والمدرسة أو الشقة على كل شيء
لم يكن لدينا حفلة بيانكا من جانبه
لا يرى المال حقا الخيانة
هذه المنشورات بدأت كل شيء
لقد التقطت هذه الصور بنفسي
ثم المشاغب بلدي هو سيء
جلست بالأكسجين شبان غير عاديين
سمال الجسور الدايم كلاب من هذا الشخص
لكن المعدن الخاص هو fuma irina aliki
خندق على قناة هذا النوع من العلم
قدمي سجين
[موسيقى]
خلاف ذلك luces أو ضئيلة أن تعطي وتستند
مع الفئران oao لسابا تاتيانا
لينا ثم يأخذون عقليا شخص ما وليس
لا تزال تعريفة المصنع أو المنزل
الحالم 1 أنت لا تعرف أبدًا نعم أنا في خمسة ماذا
قد أبدأ في نوبات غضب ، ماذا سأفعل
ليس هناك مهر ولا أدرك ما خطبتي
حدث ذلك عندما خرجت من غيبوبة
موضحًا أن لدي ثلاثة أيام من ذلك اليوم
الساعة 12 صباحًا وأتذكر أنها كانت الساعة 9 وأنا
أنا لا أسأل نفسي حتى الأسئلة
هذا هو أن تأخذ هذه الثلاثة كل شيء جاهز
إنها معجزة نجوت منها
كل الجدية لا تزال مشهورة
[موسيقى]
الأربعاء ايرينا
يمكن أن شريط ضعيف مازا كسر بالفعل
فندق ألما بر حتى كلاهما
وفي حيفا أخشى أن أخاف على الإطلاق
ما زلت أتذكر شخص حتى أنه
هناك في الرأس وتستمر في مضاعفة نفسها
دعنا نذهب إليه بدون أن أكون معها
لا يوجد منزل ولكن توجد قلعة
كما لو أن شخصًا يعيش هنا
جرحني
مينسك من مارغريتا غراتشيفا وأنا سأستلقي عليها
Letah Dima مفتاح أن يكون Saida Ton على Midu
لا تدعهم أربات أوليا الفنلندية أنت أجيل
البيدو أنا سلف كتبنا أمي
وفي السنة الأولى لم أرغب في الكتابة إليّ
قلت أنه ربما سنكتب ، استعدت لا و
أنا متعب جسديًا فقط
ثابت يعيد غسل هذه المقابلة
كل هذه القصص ولكن معي كل منها
بمجرد الخوض في القمامة ولا نسأل
الذين صعدوا من خلاله كما لو كان خطًا فاخرًا ستراه
كانت هناك علاقات في زواجنا
لحظة سعيدة حقا لي اثنان
الأطفال الذين كانوا من أجل الحب و
التخطيط فقط انقلب كل شيء رأسًا على عقب
ثواني لذلك بالنسبة لي أنا فقط
أردت أن أظهر أن هذا هو الحب و
الفظائع ولكن إذا أراد شخص ما الكتابة
نعم ، بالطبع ، دعهم يحاولون تأليف كتاب
بالنسبة للبعض قد يكون
من الأسهل من الناحية النفسية الكتابة عليه
الافراج عن ورقة الموقف
في القاعدة ، بعد كل شيء ، عندما تكون لا تزال بيديها ، حسنًا ، أنا
أريد أن أكتب كتابًا لدي بالفعل عنوان
وجه ندوب شظايا الحب
ولأنني كنت أشعر بالعار ، فقد ظهر
من الشظايا التي لحقت بهم احب ابدا
بدأ الرجل بجنون الحب انتهى
طقس سيء مجنون الاستيقاظ في الصباح للعمل
السبت لم أفكر في ذلك معي
سيحدث أسوأ شيء في حياتي
[موسيقى]
القانون ضروري العنف الأسري
تكون أدوات والكثير من الأدوات و
اختيار هذه الأدوات
[موسيقى]
ها أنت ذا
إصابة واحدة لكل حي
بولياكوفا
يليه الموت أذى جسدي فادح للجميع
كل الضربات الناجحة هناك 30 لم تكن كذلك
من السهل بما فيه الكفاية الفتيات فقط لا
كان لدي ما يكفي من القوة ، حاول خلع كيف
مرة واحدة على الأقل في ممارسة الجنس الجماعي الرياضي
الذل لا يزال ينتظر
تقريبا واحدة من الفتيات
انتحرت جدا هي و
انتهى تناوله في وقته
أنقذت
لا أفهم ما يشبه اهتزازات جيبون
لم يكن لديهم خيار آخر
كلها غير قابلة للإثبات ولا يمكن أن تكون ونحن بالفعل
سنة ونصف في الواقع
نقول كل شيء للناس لماذا لا نفعل
يسمع
[موسيقى]
في اللحظة التي أحمل فيها 4 معي
لا شيء مثل هذا الرنين
لقد تغيرنا كنا نناقش حوله لمدة عامين
القانون ومع ذلك في أي مكان من الطين
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
نمط
لا بأس في الوقوف في الشرف
ثم العمل ثم في المساء كل شيء
نمر بكل شيء ، نحن نرتاح حقًا
اتبع قبل وصوله من العمل
لدينا رجل
[موسيقى]
على التوقف
سيلين
المادة 105 الجزء 1 المحاصيل الملوحة
لدي جسم صنعته
يوجد تنظيف على حافة المطبخ
تأطير مثلث برمودا
شربوا على الهواء مباشرة الضرر
[موسيقى]
مرة واحدة دون دم ، ثم شربوا المزيد و
كل شيء على ما يرام مثل
تم الاجتياز بنجاح
[موسيقى]
دمية الوشم سمولينسك سيئة هنا الزوج adyge
أنا قاطعت المصعد الذي تم شفاؤه إلى
كل من الحرارة والهدوء matlin autolady
بلاد ما بين النهرين
ايداهو يصل نوافذ ويعطي كل من saculin
العرق هو ماء حقيقي من خلال عرض متر للقصر
نسيت المادة 105 الجزء 1 و 111 الجزء 2 4
كان الآخر يشتم
فقط افتراء
الزوجة الأولى سممت نفسها
قاتل الربيع
بعد كل شيء ، الصمت طلق الزوجة الرابعة
[موسيقى]
من الصعب أن تتوب بالطبع يمكنك ذلك
تصرفنا بشكل مختلف
عزيزي لشرح قال بطريقة أو بأخرى
قصتي المعتادة
لأنه في تلك اللحظة لا أعرف ماذا و
شعور
عندما أخذت لأقول
أفهم كل شيء وأتذكر كل شيء على أكمل وجه
[موسيقى]
مونش ليزا تاتيانا بوركينا الكسندر
صندوق وعقل الشطرنج هو سلعة
tatyana madinat olegu من خلال إلقاء اللوم على أوليا
أنا سهل وسأستلقي في المنزل ، امرأة مع ذكرى فاكهة أو
فرع تاتيانا مها جول
كل شيء يعمل بها صالون سخيف مسنن
تشحن عليا عايزين معها وفكرت
الكسندرا بردونوف لديها موهبة بحتة
تاتيانا أتاتات أخصائي الطهي في حانة الطاغية
[موسيقى]
إنه رجل طيب يريد الآباء والأمهات
قابله وشكره
أنت رجل قاسي المستوى تعرض للضرب بهذا
أنا لا أصدقك
اضطررت إلى حجز فاتورة طاولة
منع العنف المنزلي اعتقدت
وهكذا أدركت أنني كنت أنا فقط
السنة الجديدة الافتراء والشكوى
طرد من الشقة دون دليل
قالت المرأة إن للرجل قرائن
اللوم في الواقع
وبدأت أفريقيا سالي ألا شاكو توريدو
الشريط الكهرماني اسم بيتا هذا بالضبط لـ
مقاييس العقل وسوني ألفا له كرة واحدة
كان الوداع مثل هذا مع الأكبر
ابنة آخذ أنا أحبك لقد فهمت بالفعل
ربما لن أراها لفترة طويلة
يجب أن يتجه القطار نحو
تاجانروج
سأحاول رؤية الأطفال الذين ليسوا كذلك
لقد رأيته لمدة 9 سنوات ، كل شيء سيكون جيدًا للغاية هناك
الصعب
ستكون هناك ، كالعادة ، نوبات غضب وأنت
الملتحي لهؤلاء بالفعل و sobek
تضرب المرأة في الرأس والروح
أنت نيوتن يتم التنمر عليه جيدًا
في المجتمع الحديث ، وبعضها كذلك
يمكن للأزواج أيضًا أن يكون عارياً
إنها مثل هناك ومن جانب الذكور و
أنثى
[موسيقى]
أعتقد أنك تفهم ذلك
حدث اليوم أدرك حتى النهاية جيدا
في الوقت الحالي بلدي لا يحبني
لا لحماية لحظة المستقبل وبالطبع
أخشى أن يخرج ليقتلني أيضًا
لأنه مرر لي ملاحظات
انتظره وحين وزنه يوم 11 ديسمبر قال
قال ذلك انتظرني إذا لم يكن كذلك
انتظر تلك اليد الزرقاء لوالدك
لذلك بالطبع أنا خائف من مستقبلي
إلقاء نظرة على يديك مشكلة الخلاف
[موسيقى]